[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK ORLOVE: Hi, everyone.
And welcome to CE Chat.
Today, we're graciously hosted
by the Cloud on Air folks.
They run a webinar
every Tuesday.
Make sure you dial in weekly.
They do a lot of
exciting topics.
My name is Nick Orlove,
and I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud.
And with me is Chris Talbott.
Chris, you want to introduce
yourself real quick?
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah, sure thing.
Hello, everyone.
Chris-- I'm the product
marketing manager
for the storage
and data transfer
portfolio at Google Cloud.
And today, we're going
to talk about how to get
your data into Google Cloud.
Because there's a bunch of
different options for migrating
data, some of which
might be relevant
to a particular workload
or a particular situation
that you have in
your data center
or with another Cloud provider.
But the topic begs
the question, why
do you want to get your data
into Google Cloud platform
in the first place?
What can you do with it?
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, actually,
that's very relevant.
So exactly to your point, to
step back and talk about why
you should, or how to basically
optimize moving your data,
it's best to talk about why move
your data in the first place.
So until recently,
most customers
were interested in
moving workloads
to Cloud because of the
infrastructure optimization.
So you'd have an application
that's running in Place A,
whether that's on prem, maybe
a co-location or something,
and you want to
move it to the Cloud
so you can utilize benefits
of cost efficiency,
maybe you need to scale your
workload, something like that.
You want to store some
backups in the Cloud, maybe
some bursting.
But recently, we've definitely
seen a lot of customers
be interested in the more
digital transformation
piece of moving a
workload to the Cloud.
And I know digital
transformation kind of sounds
like a little buzz word.
But actually, it's really true.
So we're seeing lots of
conversations with customers
in executive level
conversations, board level
conversations about
how can we leverage
some of the native
benefits of Cloud
that we're not really
utilizing today?
So whether those benefits
being moving all your data so
that you can actually analyze
your data-- so if you have
terabytes or potentially
petabytes of data,
it might not be quite so cost
efficient to do that on prem.
Maybe it's using Google's
machine learning capabilities.
We have some really impressive
natural APIs or capabilities
with TensorFlow.
And leveraging that in our
Cloud is much more beneficial,
because we've already
done the legwork for you.
Other things-- maybe
hosting your application,
integration with partners,
scaling out for employees,
making things a lot
easier for them.
There's lots of
different reasons.
But today we're here to
talk about efficiently
migrating your data.
So that implies that there's
somewhat of a challenge.
So Chris, what
kind of challenges
are there with moving your data?
CHRIS TALBOTT: There's a lot of
challenges to moving your data,
largely due to the
world we live in when
it comes to data creation.
So companies,
individuals, governments,
organizations-- everyone
is creating data
at an incredible rate.
Pick your favorite analysts.
We see data growth percentages
in, like, 50% year over year.
We've talked to
plenty of customers
who are actually doubling
their data year over year.
NICK ORLOVE: Wow.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And when you're
dealing with that much data,
it becomes challenging
to move it.
Because there's all sorts
of complexities involved
in moving data from Point A
to Point B. A lot of times
you run into network challenges.
It actually can be very
expensive to upgrade
your network.
You may not have
dedicated bandwidth
to just dedicate it all to
moving a large amount of data.
And it takes really
specialized resources
to start to build new
network infrastructure.
So a lot of customers
are struggling with that.
They're also struggling
with just something that's
in the nature of
moving data, in that it
comes with a lot of
specific challenges.
Because you want to ensure that
the data that you're moving,
when it ends up in
its destination,
is exactly the same as where
it was in its source, right?
NICK ORLOVE: Makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
there's a whole process
through checksumming,
running into firewalls.
Like, ensuring that
that is complete
and the data integrity
as it moves along the way
can be very, very complicated.
And then, just
generally, everyone
is strapped for
time and resources.
And moving large amounts of
data can take a lot of time
and a lot of resources.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And even when
you're incredibly successful,
like Evernote was in
migrating essentially
their entire infrastructure
over to Google Cloud platform,
you can see it's a really
challenging process.
So Evernote actually wrote
this incredible five part blog
series about their
migration effort.
So I encourage everyone
to go and check it out.
And they describe
exactly what goes
into doing a migration
of this size, which
was over three petabytes
of data and five
billion notes and
attachments within Evernote.
NICK ORLOVE: Including my
note somewhere, I guess.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Absolutely.
And they dedicated a
team of eight engineers
and a serious amount of time to
managing this migration effort.
Now.
We know that you, as
customers and prospects,
want to get your
data to the Cloud.
And not everyone
has the resources
available like an Evernote or
can dedicate all their time
to this huge migration.
So we want to offer
solutions, regardless
where you are on that journey,
to get your data to the Cloud
efficiently.
So let's talk about some
of those solutions that are
available from Google Cloud.
And we'll talk first
about why the challenge is
so difficult for moving
such a large amount of data,
like three petabytes
that Evernote did.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
I want to ask--
so three petabytes in 70 days
sounds really impressive.
But how do I kind
of perceptualize
that in terms of
what that equates to?
So can you lay out,
just kind of associating
what three petabytes is
like and network speeds
and stuff like that?
CHRIS TALBOTT:
Yeah, definitely--
first, we can talk
about the one challenge
that we all face in moving data.
And no matter how hard
we try, even as Google,
we're not going to break
the speed of light barrier,
which is essentially the
determining factor when
you're moving data from
Point A to Point B.
NICK ORLOVE: Makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
regardless of where
you are on this
spectrum of data sizes,
you can see on the left-hand
side of this slide,
you're going to come up to
essentially an opposing network
bandwidth in order
to move that size.
So it's sort of this dichotomy
between amount of data
and network availability.
And you find yourself
somewhere on this graph
for a particular data set.
So in the customers
that I have talked to,
and I'm sure you've
talked to, too,
we see that a typical enterprise
has data sets or data corpuses
of single digit petabyte.
Let's call, like,
an average, right?
And you can see, as you
go along the spectrum
for the available
network, we oftentimes
see people in 100 megabits
or maybe a gigabit per second
[INAUDIBLE], right?
So drag your eye down to
the middle of that graph.
You could be facing
somewhere in the neighborhood
of 124 days to three years to
move your data to Google Cloud
Platform.
I bet that your business
doesn't want to run
in that kind of time frames.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
If my CEO's telling me that we
need to transform our business,
I can't tell him, well, we
need to wait three months, four
months, a year to do it.
So yeah, that makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
regardless of where
you are on the spectrum,
both network availability
and the amount of data
that you want to move,
Google Cloud wants to
provide solutions for you
to get your data to the Cloud
quickly and efficiently.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
let's talk about a few
of these options that are
available from Google Cloud
platform.
And there's basically
four core solutions
that we have for migrating data
into Google Cloud platform.
And we're really talking about
just the act of migrating data.
So not professional
services engagement,
where you would migrate
VMs and all the things that
are associated with that.
This is physically
moving bits from one--
NICK ORLOVE: Moving bits.
CHRIS TALBOTT:
--place to another.
So the first one, which
almost all of our customers
use in some form or
fashion, is gsutil,
which is a command line
interface for moving data,
typically from on premises
into Google Cloud Storage.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: The
second option that we
have is a transfer service.
And I like to refer to
this as our Cloud to Cloud
transfer service.
Basically, if you
have data today
that is in cloud storage,
whether from another cloud
vendor like Microsoft or
Amazon, or you have it
somewhere in Google Cloud
Storage, a particular region
that you might want
to move it from,
this is a great
solution for that.
The third option,
which I am actually
going to spend some
more time later
in this presentation
going through,
because we just reached a major
milestone with this product
in reaching general
availability,
is Transfer Appliance, which
is a relatively new product
from Google Cloud that
physically moves data.
It's really good for
when you have situations
where you have a lot of data and
not great network availability.
NICK ORLOVE: Yep.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And
then finally, we
have a solution that helps
automate the transfer of data
from marketing tools into
BigQuery for analysis.
Because a lot of companies
are focusing on the data
that they capture about their
customers and prospects,
and they want to
analyze that data.
NICK ORLOVE: Makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And for
these latter three options,
we also have many
partners in our network
that can help in these
sort of situations, too.
NICK ORLOVE: That's
good to hear.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
So let's talk really quickly
about Cloud storage transfer
service.
So basically, very simply,
this product or service--
it moves data from a source
to what we call a data sync.
Now you could call
it a sink, a bathtub,
a pool-- whatever
you want to call it.
What it's going
to end up being in
is a Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
So you are moving data
from a cloud storage source
to a Google Cloud
storage bucket.
It's really good
to use this product
when you want to synchronize
your data from source
to your Google Cloud
storage bucket.
You expect things
to change, you want
to make sure the source
and the destination match.
It also automates the
deletion of source data
once you move it or vise versa.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, that's great.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So you can,
for lack of a better word,
it essentially has
checksumming between the source
and the destination
of your data.
And for those customers who
are already using Google Cloud
storage and, say, you want
to move from one region
to another region, or you want
to tier a large amount of data
from hot storage
to cold storage,
it's also good for
that kind of use case.
And BigQuery data transfer
service, like I mentioned,
is the tool for marketers.
So lots of marketers are
using BigQuery to analyze
what their customers are doing.
And this tool is fully
managed data import service
for Google BigQuery.
So you see some of the
very popular ads, products,
on the left-hand
side of the screen--
YouTube, AdWords, DoubleClick.
BigQuery can automate
the transfer of data
from those products
directly into BigQuery.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
that's really cool.
And what's nice is
that BigQuery is
used for all sorts of
different data sets--
data types for analyzing
data, whether it's ad hoc,
batch analysis,
streaming, et cetera.
But it's not just
for the data that you
use through your marketing
data or what have you.
So we have customers who import
their data with SaaS sources.
For instance, if you
have marketing data,
you have CRM data,
maybe event-driven data,
or maybe you have databases--
so SQL data, whether it's
a MySQL, or PostgreS, SQL
Server, or even Oracle, finding
some way of basically
moving that data
so that you can perform lots of
analysis on multiple data sets,
combining the things together
to get one rational picture.
And even your existing
data warehouses--
so if you have Teradata,
Netezza, et cetera,
it's really a great source of
basically housing your data.
And I like how you
called it your sink,
your pool, et cetera.
That's definitely applicable,
because we meet customers
wherever they are.
And the benefit of
BigQuery is that we
scale to meet their demands.
So whether you have just
a couple gigs, a couple
terabytes, a couple petabytes,
dozens of petabytes,
we can definitely meet you
where you're at with BigQuery.
And we have partners,
as you can see
on the screen, who are able
to help migrate that data.
So whether you are working with
a SaaS application or a storage
application in
terms of databases,
we have a bunch of
partners who are
able to help migrate
that data efficiently
and move it into BigQuery
for further analysis.
CHRIS TALBOTT: That's great.
NICK ORLOVE: So I guess--
let me ask the question of--
so let's say that I
have a slow network,
and I want to migrate a
whole lot of data over.
What are my options?
CHRIS TALBOTT: Well, we
have a product for you.
[LAUGHTER]
So Transfer Appliance--
I said I wanted
to take a little bit more
time to talk about Transfer
Appliance, because it's a brand
new product to the portfolio,
essentially.
It's our rackable, high
capacity storage server
for shipping large amounts
of data to Google Cloud
rather than sending
it over the network.
So you can see on the
screen, right here
is the 100 terabyte raw
capacity version, which,
with compression,
you can achieve
potentially double that
amount of data on the device
and then send us 200 terabytes.
We also have a [? 4U ?] version,
480 terabytes of raw capacity.
And this device could move
up to a petabyte of data
to the Cloud.
And what's amazing is
it does it much faster
than a typical
network would do it.
So as we watch this
screen build out,
we can see Transfer Appliance
could move a petabyte of data
potentially, if you're
really fast with the shipping
and making sure you get
it back to us in time--
in 43 days.
Compare that to what you could
do over a typical network.
That's like 96% faster
to move your data.
So back to your
comment about CEOs
want to move at the
speed of, you know,
digital transformation--
this is a product
that could help you do that
and get your data to the Cloud
faster.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
CHRIS TALBOTT: It's also
a really simple process,
similar to e-commerce
and online shopping.
So all you have to do is go
into the Google Cloud console.
You request a
Transfer Appliance.
We'll actually reach out
and work with you to size
the right appliance
for your workload.
A lot of folks who might
have small amounts of data
and perhaps Transfer
Appliance isn't necessarily
the best solution.
We could probably do it with
gsutil or some networking
solutions.
Perhaps, say, it falls somewhere
in between that 100 terabytes
and 480 terabytes,
and they don't
know should I order four of
one and one of the other?
So we'll help you out with
that, with those considerations.
Once you request
the appliance, we
ship it by regular shipping
carriers like FedEx and UPS.
You receive the appliance.
You actually, if you
want to, can rack it
in your data center.
Which is one of the reasons
why we built transfer
appliance the way that we did.
Because we know,
one, lots of folks
have existing data centers.
And two, those
data centers don't
come with space
for various devices
to be littered around the floor.
NICK ORLOVE: True.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And
three, if you're
moving a petabyte
of data, it's going
to have to live there
for a little while
as it captures all of the
data that you want to move.
So you can actually rack
Transfer Appliance in your data
center, connect
it to the network,
fill it up with up to
a petabyte of data,
if you buy the big one.
And then you ship the
appliance back to Google,
where we stage that in a Google
Cloud Storage bucket, where
the data then gets decrypted.
It's encrypted the entire time.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh,
that's good to know.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So your data
is secure as you transfer it.
And then all you do is, you log
back into Google Cloud Storage.
You supply the decryption keys.
Decrypt that data.
And we'll have it available in
a Google Cloud Storage bucket
and then can make that
data available to all
of the services that you may
want to use from Google Cloud
platform.
NICK ORLOVE: Nice.
And these are decryption
keys that I as a customer
set myself, and
so Google doesn't
know what data I'm sending
or has any access to any
of that stuff.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
Because as the data transfers
via FedEx across the country
and wherever you
may be sending it,
we want that data
to be protected.
So it's going to be
encrypted the entire time.
And once the data
transfer is complete,
the appliances are raised
per the standards, which
[? I ?] feel confident with.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So I mentioned
this product recently
hit a milestone of becoming
generally available.
And this happened about two
weeks ago at the end of June.
And a few new
features were included
in general availability
that I think
would be super interesting
to the audience.
One is you can now
mount your transfer
points when you receive it
as network attached storage.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, nice.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So we
know probably anywhere
from a third to half
of the workloads
in a typical enterprise
are referencing
some sort of file storage.
So I just want to make it really
easy for you to drag and drop
your files or rsync those
files from where they are today
into a Transfer Appliance.
We released an in
console request process,
so you can see and
request transfer appliance
in the same console that you're
using Google Cloud Storage
and all the other services.
And then, an end
to end integrity
check-- so this goes back
to one of those challenges
that I mentioned at the
beginning of the presentation.
You want to ensure that the
bits in the source and the bits
in the destination
are exactly the same.
Because you want any application
that's referencing them,
any analyst who wants to analyze
that data to ensure they're
looking at the same data.
So we have an end to
end integrity check
to make sure that you're
confident in doing so.
NICK ORLOVE: Yep.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
Transfer Appliance
has been in beta
for about a year.
And through that process,
we were able to learn,
from the many customers
who use it, some really
cool use cases that Transfer
Appliance is particularly
successful with.
So I thought I'd bring that
up to get the ideas flowing
about ways that folks may
use Transfer Appliance today.
So one of the really
interesting ones
is to use it to seed
a proof of concept
for another Google
Cloud product.
So you mentioned machine
learning and AI initiatives.
Lots of customers
want to do that.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, yeah.
CHRIS TALBOTT: We
have lots of APIs,
like ML Vision or the
image recognition APIs.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So if you
want to test those on, say,
like, a large corpus of images
that you have on premises
today, say 100 terabyte
library of images--
a good way to send that
to us and check out
some of our machine
learning solutions
would be to use a
Transfer Appliance
and transfer that data.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Makes sense.
CHRIS TALBOTT: One that we
didn't necessarily expect,
but bubbled up as a
really cool use case
is to collect data from
other vendors or research
organizations and bring that
to Google Cloud for analysis.
So you can actually send
Transfer Appliance out
to geographic or
weather data vendors,
collect data there,
and bring it in.
And I'll talk about
a couple of customers
in a second that are
using it in that manner.
Lots of folks have a
transfer process today that's
usually disparate, very manual.
You're collecting tapes.
You're restoring those tapes.
You may be pulling data from
a [INAUDIBLE] source on prem.
And then you're kind of getting
all that data together and then
sending it over.
Transfer Appliance
can help with that.
Of course, data
center migrations,
as you move to the Cloud
and through the data center
migration, what we find
customers doing is they're
taking the opportunity to kind
of clean their storage house,
delete the data that's
no longer needed,
and only move the good stuff,
which a Transfer Appliance can
be a catalyst for.
NICK ORLOVE: Definitely.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
And then finally, what it's
probably most often used
for in the best
use case is really
dense, rich, large
amounts of content.
So media archives,
images, regulatory content
that you need to
keep for seven years
because you're FCC
regulated, for instance--
you can move that data to the
Cloud using Transfer Appliance.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So I mentioned--
I talked about a few
interesting customers.
This first one, Schmidt
Ocean Institute,
it's a nonprofit
research organization.
It's really interesting.
They're actually the
only research vessel
with a high performance
computing center on board.
NICK ORLOVE: Wow.
While they're sailing
and everything.
CHRIS TALBOTT: While
they are sailing.
And what that offers
the researchers
is access to technology
in the moment, when
they're gathering data.
And then also the
ability to capture
more and different types of
data that they never had before.
So what they do is
they actually mount
Transfer Appliance
onboard the RV Falkor
as it goes on its expedition.
They collect all the data
to Transfer Appliance.
And then, when they
come back to port,
that data gets sent to
Google Cloud storage.
And then, that's how
they distribute the data
that they collected to
all the researchers.
NICK ORLOVE: Huh, interesting.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
Airbus, and in particular, its
Airbus Defense and Space Geo
arm of Airbus, they use
Transfer Appliance to really
lift and improve their
storage architecture.
So they have access to
some really exclusive radar
and different types
of satellites.
I mean, they're capturing
these Earth observation images.
And they're providing
access to that library
of images to the world.
You can see the
image on the screen.
It's actually of Black
Rock City from Burning Man.
NICK ORLOVE: I noticed.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
they're capturing
all these amazing images.
Obviously, that accounts
for a lot of data
that they were
collecting on premises.
So they use Transfer Appliance
to move that data to the Cloud.
Beatport has a really
interesting use case.
And they want to be able to
serve their library of music
content as fast as
possible to listeners.
So they used Transfer
Appliance to move
the entire digital
library that they
have into Google Cloud Storage.
Because they knew that Google
Cloud Storage performance,
in particular with content
serving, is the best out there.
And then finally, I mentioned
that interesting use
case of collecting
research from vendors.
So this is actually a Google
X company called Makani.
And what they do, you
can see in the image,
is they fly wind kites
really high up in the air.
Because it turns out
the wind blows harder
if you go up a few
hundred meters, right?
So they can generate
energy faster
with turbines that are a
hundred meters into the air
than you could in something
that's just a typical windmill.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
Wow.
That's got to be an interesting
challenge to deal with.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
But it's really important that
they pick the right spots.
Because you need to pick an area
that weather-wise and wind-wise
is appropriate.
So they use Transfer
Appliance to collect data
from research vendors,
bring it into Google Cloud.
and then analyze and
run some models on that
to pick where they're going
to tether their wind kites.
Now regardless of what your
use case is, what kind of data
you're moving, it's going to
end up in Google Cloud Storage.
So let's take a second
to introduce or remind
folks of what Google
Cloud Storage is.
It's our object
storage solution.
It's one product, which
is very important.
Because that's differentiated
in the marketplace.
It essentially comes
in four flavors,
based on the availability
or redundancy
that you need for your
particular workload.
So from left to
right on this screen,
you have multi-regional, which
means geo redundant storage,
regional, which means in
one particular region where
your data is stored.
Nearline and Coldline, which are
essentially cold and archival
storage options.
And the price follows
the availability
from left to right
on this screen.
NICK ORLOVE: And Chris,
I've got a question for you.
And just as a reminder
to you, our audience,
there's live Q&A at the bottom.
So make sure you type
in these questions.
And we'll answer some
questions at the end.
But I frequently hear this
question from customers
of-- all right, so there's
four different tiers of GCS--
the Multiregional, Regional,
Nearline, and Coldline.
That kind of implies that,
as you tier things down,
you're getting a
degraded performance.
I mean, how does
performance work
in terms of these
different four flavors?
CHRIS TALBOTT: .
Yeah that's a really
good question.
And it's a really awesome
answer from Google,
because it doesn't change.
So the user experience
of requesting
a object in Multiregional
or requesting
an object in Coldline
will be exactly the same.
It will come back in
milliseconds of latency--
because essentially, a
single API across these.
We just allow you the
option to tier that storage
based on costs.
Or stuff that's not going to
get accessed as frequently.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, OK.
That makes sense.
Cool.
So I have, obviously, a lot of
customers who are using GCS.
And so I think it's
valuable to talk
about the different reasons
people typically use GCS.
And those generally fall
into the three buckets
that you see on the screen.
So first being content
storage and delivery--
so GCS is essentially
limitless object storage.
So whether you're storing videos
like Vimeo, music like Spotify,
websites, multimedia, maybe
your mobile web applications,
it is a fantastic place
for storing your content
for the delivery through--
whether it be through CDNs,
or, like you said, through the
incredible latency that GCS
naturally provides.
The second big category
is around data analytics
and general compute.
So if anyone is familiar with
Hadoop, for instance, or GCE,
you can leverage Dataproc to
store all of your back end
analytics data that you're
going to crawl through, create
Hadoop clusters, destroy
Hadoop clusters, et cetera.
And it really helps
in terms of being
able to scale storage and
compute independently.
And so we have a
bunch of customers,
for instance, the
Broad Institute,
who uses GCS for doing
some genomics data.
Because obviously, those
genomic data sets are massive.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: Or Philips
is another example
of being able to collect
all of that IT sensor data
from everyone really
across the globe
and being able to surface
it up through the Philips
app, et cetera, being able
to drive a lot more insights
and capabilities
to their customers
than what would have
normally been possible.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
NICK ORLOVE: And then
the final category
being kind of the general
backup, archival, and storage
repository for your data.
So if you are interested in,
for instance, a hybrid cloud
approach or multi
cloud approach,
being able to store your
data in multiple places,
whether that be through a
backup, through an archive.
And what's nice, is that
we work with a whole bunch
of different partners, for
instance, [INAUDIBLE] NetApp,
[INAUDIBLE],, Veritas, et cetera,
where you can essentially
leverage your existing solution
on prem or in the Cloud.
And then configure as a
backup repository GCS,
so that you can store
your backup data in GCS
more efficiently.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah, most
of those most common backup
providers you can just
choose GCS as a drop down.
NICK ORLOVE:
Exactly, yeah, yeah.
I've done it before.
Yep.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So I wanted
to kind of double click
on one point.
I mentioned one product
per GCS, which is really
important in the storage world.
Because when it
comes to storage,
we want a lot of rich features.
You want to have some of
your data being geo redundant
in case of a disaster.
You probably want some of your
data to be pushed to the edge,
close to your users as
possible so that the experience
is really, really fast.
You want to have some of
your data in cold storage,
so that you don't have to pay
as much because it's not getting
used for the next three years.
So with Google
Cloud Storage, you
get all of those features
in one single product,
in a single API.
Where if you went out in
the marketplace, typically
you're going to have to purchase
multiple products in order
to achieve the same
amount of functionality.
So I kind of wanted to prove
that really quick in a demo.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
Let's do it.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So we're
going to talk, in particular,
about edge caching.
So obviously, lots of customers
serve content to users.
And they serve content to those
users throughout the globe.
So what I'm going
to essentially mimic
is a user requesting
content from far away.
And let's see how fast
Google Cloud Storage
can get it to them.
NICK ORLOVE: Put it to the test.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
So we're going to make
this as hard as possible.
We're going to choose
the region that's
farthest away from us today.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So anyone
can go to this site.
It's called GCPing.com.
And it basically will tell me
how far away these regions are.
So right now, it thinks that
I'm farthest away from Frankfurt
and Belgium, Sydney, Finland--
great.
So we can choose Belgium region.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Oh,
I'll have to continue
my Google Cloud [INAUDIBLE].
So first, I will
create a bucket.
Actually, for the sake of time,
I'm looking at the screen,
I'm going to use one of the
buckets I've already created.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So if
we go back to this,
let's see if I have one that's
pretty far that I already
have a bucket for.
So Mumbai is actually
really, really far away.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So
305 milliseconds--
so I have a Mumbai
bucket, thankfully.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: And
we'll take a look
at the data that's in
this Mumbai bucket.
So for those who
aren't familiar,
object storage works--
essentially, you have buckets.
And you put data into that,
and you put objects into that.
So I have a bucket
in Mumbai region.
I have a few images
here available to me.
I was doing a demo in Tel
Aviv not too long ago,
so I had a picture of Tel
Aviv, a Google windfarm photo.
And actually, I have this
photo of this Lego figurine
in a chicken suit.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
As you would.
CHRIS TALBOTT: As we would.
So I'm going to ask--
once I reconnect this shell--
I'm essentially going to ask
the system how long it takes
for me standing here to request
that image, the Lego chicken
image, from Mumbai.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, because
it's currently [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRIS TALBOTT:
And go round trip.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So I
have the script already
run this time, Pearl.
It's going to essentially
give me that information.
And we will wait a second.
And then, here you can
see it takes 1.6 seconds.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Right?
Which is actually super fast.
When you think about far
that data is traveling.
But with Google
Cloud Storage, we
can do this much, much faster.
Because we have edge
caching actually
built into our solution.
So once I share
this image publicly,
I'll run the Pearl again.
We'll do that one more time.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, wow.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Down
to 20 milliseconds.
NICK ORLOVE: Jeez.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Because--
NICK ORLOVE: 1.6 to 0.02.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah.
That's incredible.
And it's like 99 something
percent, probably.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So because
the GCS recognized
that I'm the user who's
requesting this information,
and it wants to push that image
as close to me as possible,
so probably in an edge
location somewhere here
in Mountain View.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Wow.
That's cool.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So let's get
back over to the slides.
And let's talk about
the first option
that we introduced, gsutil and
some of the performance tricks
associated with that.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, definitely.
So I frequently hear this
comment from customers of--
I have a lot of
data to transfer.
I've decided on gsutil.
Are there some ways
of optimizing gsutil
so that I can migrate
the data easier?
And the answer is yes.
So there's a couple
of slides that I'll
go through, kind of tips
and tricks on how to do it.
First thing to be mindful of is
location, location, location.
So just like you showed,
if you have all your data
stored in the US, and you create
a storage bucket in Mumbai,
and then you replicate
all your data to Mumbai,
probably not going to be the
most efficient way of doing it.
In fact, we have this
site, Cloud.Google.com
/about/locations, where we
have currently over 16 regions.
I think it's 49 zones in
35 different countries
and over 100 points of presence.
So definitely find the
region that's closest to you.
In fact, later
this summer, we're
opening up a region
in Los Angeles,
which is pretty awesome.
So make sure you stay up to
date with the regions that
are available.
Secondly, if you're uploading
a lot of small files,
you may not know this.
But every object storage out
there has some sort of latency
or some sort of small overhead
that happens when you actually
push a file to the ending
destination or the ending
bucket.
So being able to
push, let's say,
500 small files of
125 kilobytes in size
actually gets associated
with a large amount
of unnecessary overhead.
So if you consider gsutil's
multi-threaded option,
the gsutil-m option,
you can actually
multithread all of these smaller
files into one big push to GCS.
And as you can see on
the graph on the left,
we did a test where
we actually saw over
four times the
amount of throughput
just by using this -m option.
So definitely something
to consider if you
have a bunch of small files.
Now conversely, if you have,
maybe, some really large files,
so you're doing some video
uploads, some multimedia
uploads, maybe some
really large log files
or something like that,
there's another option
of actually breaking one large
object into multiple smaller
objects.
And it's called composite
parallel uploads.
So we have this,
another gsutil option,
where essentially-- when you
perform an upload of, let's
say, one massive file.
So on the left, you can
see a 500 megabyte file.
We actually split that
up into multiple chunks,
upload those in
parallel, and then,
once they all arrive
in GCS, GCS actually
combines them together.
And then performs a checksum
to make sure that everything
got compiled successfully.
And as you can see on
the left-hand side,
we see quite a bit of
performance improvement
by using this option, compared
to the default option.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: Now one thing
to be aware of, though,
is that you should not be
using this for Nearline
or Coldline storage.
The reason why,
pretty simple, is
that when you upload all
these small little chunks,
and then it combines those
chunks into one big chunk,
it actually deletes
those individual chunks.
And with Nearline
and Coldline storage,
because these are longer
term storage mediums,
your objects are meant to
stay for 30 days, 90 days,
depending on the storage class.
So if you're performing a
composite parallel upload,
you're actually, behind
the scenes, deleting
each of those individual
chunks as they get
combined into one big object.
And so you'll get
charged, essentially,
for those individual chunks
that have to be deleted.
So makes sense-- just
something to be aware of.
And another thing
to keep in mind
is you have to be considerate
of sequential files.
So if you're uploading,
for instance,
log files or sensor
data that uses
a traditional or standard kind
of naming convention, what
happens under the covers
is that you're actually
uploading the sequential files
to, maybe, the same back end--
excuse me-- servers within GCS.
So you can actually
be throttling yourself
by just your naming
standard alone.
So something to keep
in mind is, maybe,
use a hash in front
of the file names,
or maybe rename your file
folders, stuff like that.
As you can see from the
screen shot on the bottom,
we saw a 2x improvement
by simply renaming files,
so another thing
to keep in mind.
And then lastly, obviously
moving your data is important.
But what if you have
an entire application
that you want to move?
You want to lift and shift
Application A from your data
center to GCP.
And you want it to remain
exactly like Application A.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: Well,
fortunately, we
have a whole bunch of
partners that we work with--
for instance, [INAUDIBLE],,
who can do that for you.
So if you have a Windows
Server, you have a Linux server,
maybe have a VM environment,
you can perform that lift
and shift quite easily.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah, awesome.
NICK ORLOVE: So, yeah.
It's fantastic.
So with that, we're going
to stay tuned for live Q&A.
So we'll be back in
less than a minute.
And we'll answer your questions.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Cool.
NICK ORLOVE: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So thank you, everyone,
for writing up
a whole bunch of questions.
We have some good ones.
So Chris, I guess I'll ask
you the first question.
When should you use gsutil
versus the storage transfer
service?
CHRIS TALBOTT: Great question--
cheaper, simple answer.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: So when
you're moving data
from on premises into
the Cloud and you
don't have the
challenges that we
talked about which would lead
you to Transfer Appliance,
use gsutil.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Because
most of our developers,
especially, use gsutil
to move their data.
If you want to go from one
cloud storage location,
whether that be in another
cloud storage provider or us,
to a Google Cloud Storage
use transfer service.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Pretty clear cut, cool.
Well, I guess onto
the second question--
how can I get the status or
other information on transfers?
Can this information
be visualized?
CHRIS TALBOTT: So status
updates and further information
on the progress
of your transfer--
that's something that we're
thinking about integrating
into the console in the future.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: We
have standard tracking
associated with the Appliance
through the shipping vendor.
And that information, it cannot
be visualized today, obviously.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
I guess I'll take the third one.
Would you recommend
the Transfer Appliance
to migrate on prem VMware
VMs to Google Cloud?
So the Transfer Appliance
is more for data
itself, rather
than applications.
So we actually have a
great solution specifically
for VMware called Velostrata.
Velostrata was actually a
company that Google acquired,
I think it was about a month
ago, maybe two months ago.
But it's really easy to,
basically, migrate your VMware
VMs by essentially
installing little agents,
I think on vCenter.
And then you have some
new options in VMware
to essentially create the
destination where you're
going to replicate your VM to.
You'll, in the background,
synchronize the data.
And then we make it
very easy for you
to perform that cut over
migration once you have all
the networking, the
firewalls, all the kind
of ancillary pieces set up.
Make it really easy for you.
And by the way, the
Velostrata solution
is totally free for performing
migrations into GCP.
I mean, obviously,
there's GCP costs
of running your VM on GCP.
But the actual act of
migration through Velostrata
is totally free.
So definitely check it out.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: I guess I'll
take number four, as well.
Rather than uploading my data
onto the Transfer Appliance,
can I just ship you a
copy of my storage array?
This is interesting.
Because I used to be in
the storage industry,
so I'm very familiar
with the storage arrays.
So the answer is,
unfortunately, no.
You can't just ship us
your EMC or your NetApp
or what have you--
storage array.
At least, you can't ship us it.
But we do work with partners
like Iron Mountain, where
you can ship your
storage to our partners.
And they have incredibly fast
backbone network connection
to GCP, and they can suck
all the data off your storage
array, and then, put
it right into GCS.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yes.
NICK ORLOVE: And
I guess I'll have
you take the last question.
What if I have data
that changes frequently?
Can I still use the
Transfer Appliance?
CHRIS TALBOTT: Yeah,
you can use it.
But probably not in the
way that you're thinking.
So a great use case would be to
use Transfer Appliance to seed
whatever that workload is that's
going to change frequently.
So let's take backup
as an example.
You could take all of
your historical backups,
move them with
Transfer Appliance,
and then incrementally back up
over the network from there.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Right?
So if Transfer
Appliance can actually
accelerate the process
of moving your data,
even if it's going to change.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, cool.
Well, that's about it for time.
So thank you everyone
for joining us CE Chat.
Our next session is Data
Science for Social Change.
That sounds really interesting.
I'm going to be
tuning into that.
So I hope everyone sticks
around and watches that.
Until then, I guess, see
you at CE Chat next week.
Thanks, everyone.
CHRIS TALBOTT: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]